hi there steve coffin here
today is the second in this series of
short videos about stephen covey's
seven
uh habits of highly effective people and
his second habit was
to what he what he calls begin with the
end in mind this is very important i'll
give you an example i had a meeting with
about 50 chinese immigrants here in
vancouver who were complaining about the
difficulty they had in speaking english
and
they claimed that they could read
perhaps didn't understand quite as well
when they were listening but they had
real trouble saying something
my question to them is what is their
vision of what they would like to be
able to do in english
if their vision of what they want to do
in english is to be able to
when suddenly confronted with an
english-speaking person to be able to
say something in english and i should
point out that these were
housewives wives of wealthy chinese
immigrants who
don't have much interaction with
uh canadian society
but then when they are confronted with
the need to speak english of course
can't do so so what's your goal and
they're they weren't really clear and i
said that if i were you if i had
emigrated to another country my goal
because i'm an adult
and i can communicate as an adult in my
own language my goal in this new
language especially if i'm living there
is to be able to communicate as an adult
in the new language therefore on a wide
range of subjects without
struggling without seeming to be foolish
that's the goal you have to have a clear
idea of that goal and if you have a
clear idea of that goal you will achieve
it if you don't have a clear idea of
that goal if you think you're just going
to learn some words
uh and try and learn some grammar rules
and then you wonder why you can't
communicate properly
um you will probably not succeed
i always make the case if you don't
know where the top of the mountain is
if you can't visualize yourself reaching
the top of the mountain you probably
won't make it to the top of the mountain
so i think the second of covey's
habits is this habit of saying
insofar as language learning is
concerned here's what i want to achieve
i can visualize myself achieving this
and therefore i will work as hard as i
can to achieve it so that is habit
number two thank you for listening bye
for now